I looked into the because because the
information was there I looked into all
the major terrorist incidents in Europe
and all the major rampage killings in
North America and indeed Japan in in
recent years and the reason I could look
into them was because unlike most crime
these episodes are still thoroughly
covered by the media people actually do
look into the antecedents of the of the
perpetrators in a way which in lots of
cases they simply don't and what I found
was that in almost every single case the
perpetrators of these rampage killings
whether in North America or Europe or
Britain from the killers of Lee Rigby to
to Jaron Locke know the man who
massacred people in Arizona to the
killers of two Canadian soldiers to the
batterer clan killers to the guy who was
who killed people on the beach in chin
his ear at soos to the man who who
pulled a gun on the passengers in the
talus train every single one of them was
a marijuana user there are other drugs
involved as well Anders Breivik for
instance through his own testimony we
know this as Braddock was on steroids as
was there my teen the culprit of the of
the Orlando nightclub killing and indeed
the culprits of the westminster knife
attack and the London Bridge so steroids
are important as well and so our
antidepressants but marijuana plays a
very very large role in these things and
in the backgrounds of many many people
who commit serious acts and violence it
is there it's not there because they
were they were necessarily stand at the
time it's there because of its long-term
effects on people if you look if you
look at the good at the behavior of
animal rgo and animal Ally the two
killers of Lee Rigby in court you can
see that these were people who are not
wholly how shall I say not wholly
reasonable and Peter would you therefore
have it upgraded to a class a from a
Class B I think these distinctions are
more or less meaningless the distinction
the a B and C distinctions were invented
for the 1971 issues
exactly I've written about this in
detail in in my book the war we never
fought
the two things the the marijuana
legalization campaign has wanted one was
to separate marijuana from the other
bogeymen drugs at the time and at the
time they were LSD and heroin and so the
classification of a and B separated that
the other thing they wants to do is to
separate the crime of possession from
the crime of sale and trafficking to
make possession a minor crime and
trafficking a major crime there's no
logic in this if you think about it and
they achieved both of those things it's
nice to do it Class A or Class B you can
classify this class double xzh if you
don't actually prosecute which is what
we don't do then you will have no effect
and what happens at the moment is we
have a law because we're obliged most
national treaty to have that law but we
don't operate it so the actually act a
very serious crime which attracts say a
prison sentence of five years and an
unlimited fine
of possession of cannabis is pretty much
on prosecutors the police were as far as
they possibly can avoid arresting
anybody for if they do arrest them for
it they'll probably give them something
call the cannabis warning which is
meaningless if they ever are prosecuted
the the courts will will hand down the
tiniest conceivable sentence it's a law
we know for what am i changing from A to
B is is a meaningless gesture palsy what
about the kind of Portuguese model where
you decriminalize and treat as a health
issue rather than as a crime issue well
again I have to direct you because this
we could spend hours on this to a long
blog posting which I wrote on the
Portuguese drug paradise Portugal had a
very serious drug problem before these
these changes were made it didn't
actually and the the enforcement of drug
law in Portugal there have been
extremely weak the changes claimed are
perhaps a little added and maybe wrongly
attributed the for instance the
Portugal's and needle exchange program
and various other things go back a long
time
penalization and some things have got
worse particularly lifetime use of
certain drugs and i would say that i
would say this is a correlation and not
a causation that homicide and petty
crime also increased there are many
aspects to drug abuse apart from the
deaths of drug users which we have to
worry about one of them is the mental
health particularly users of cannabis
which is is seldom recorded because most
modern Western countries try as hard as
they possibly can not to get involved in
treating the mentally ill because it's
so expensive so they just shout them to
one side then you have the difficulty of
crime committed by people who've been
taking drugs which by and large police
don't record or pay any attention to and
then you have the the the the the the
general level of other crime which tends
to follow where drugs come first and I
think a serious examination of portugal
i i've tried to put to examine both
sides of the case in this long i've
written about it a serious examination
how it shows that it's by no means the
paradise that's claimed and people
should look at it more carefully before
before imagining and somehow or other
they've solved the problem in lisbon
because they have not and peter where do
you stand on the issue of addiction do
you believe that it's a mental health
condition or do you think it's an
indulgence
it's a fantasy there is no such thing i
the word has no definable meaning it's a
shapeshifter
and this is the problem with it people
will use it in two distinct ways they
will use it as if it excuses the drug
user from from taking the drug there's a
totally overwhelms his or her will so
that he has no choice but to take it and
they will use it in another way to
suggest the opposite it cannot be both
either you can stop or you cannot stop
in my view you can and many people do
and I think the treating of what is
effectively a crime as an illness is
very dangerous I it's also rather
insulting to people who are genuinely
ill and no one no one no one voluntarily
gets cancer no one voluntarily gets
leukemia no one voluntarily gets
tuberculosis these are illnesses these
can be treated people who start taking
powerful psychotropic
illegal drugs do
as an active voluntary will and also
they don't become habituated which is as
far as I prepared together and become
habituated immediately it could take
quite a LeFort to get habituated to any
drug these people should not be treated
as if they were ill they should be
treated as if they are voluntary
criminals and and if we did that I
promised you we'd have a lot fewer of
them and if you really are seriously
concerned about the suffering which is
caused by these drugs both to the people
who take them and to their families and
to their neighbors and to their
workmates and to the and to the
taxpayers who who who get mugs to give
them their methadone if you're seriously
concerned about all these things then
you should be trying to prevent people
becoming a bit chill drug users and I
think a judicious application of the
criminal law would be a much better way
of doing that there any amount of
so-called treatment
[Music]